and now Tim Dylan is going to have
[Music]
babe Nancy Pelosi's like some of your
faves will be implicated it was just
always know you should support those
documents the other way stop is it okay
let's not okay okay
we on we're in we're live everybody
funniest quotes shofar bet - Jeffrey
Epstein thing was who was it it was
Pelosi's daughter no Pelosi said some of
you some of our faves will be implicated
that was Pelosi or her daughter
well I think it was her daughter you
know it's a little bit more
understandable cuz she's gay right
Christine Christine Christine she's like
a documentary filmmaker yeah it's quite
likely that some of our faves are
implicated in the horrific yes
trafficking some of our faves are gonna
be implicated in the horrific child rape
and torture these are some of our faves
listen yeah there's like should be like
an emoji in that yeah don't listen yes
Yas Queen
okay so here's the deal they were tied
up some of our faves are participating
in human trafficking that we know but
they're still our faves there's still
like our faves don't forget the good
times like the fun times that we had
with them the SNL skits about them yeah
that were just fun these are our faves
these are like the people that we grew
up with okay so like don't it's like a
Gilmore Girls reunion yeah some of our
fans are back
Lorelai sits out she's like Rory some of
your some of our faves are raping and
torturing children but don't forget that
time that we all went to the Christmas
tree lighting together that still means
something Rory Rory that still means
something
nobody's just any one thing someone
could be just a fun great person and
also the torturer of children yeah
innocent children but then like Trump
was there kill him right
kill drop Trump was troubles at a
cocktail party kill him I read a long
time ago that Trump was like around the
epstein ship but he liked old people to
get that Lake like get the [ __ ] away
from a young girl like Trump kicked him
out of Mara Lago because people were
complaining FC was hitting on like young
girls at the pool I think one of the
members of our Lago was like we can't
have this yeah and I think Trump you
know to his credit was like okay right
this is [ __ ] up my business now this
man sleeping with children has now
started to [ __ ] up my bottom line yeah
so let's get him out of here you know I
think I'm pretty sure I read that that
yeah no I don't know I mean sounds like
him here's my concern folks my concern
is for the Clintons I just don't want
Bill and Hillary Clinton to be ensnared
in an episode in a in a drama they had
nothing to do with this it doesn't
matter I just want them to ride off into
the sunset I said I just want them to
win again I want Hillary to get into the
Democratic primary win again build a
pardon Epstein and then no one cares
yeah
every would like Yas Quinn and they all
get on a bussines jet and just fly off
yeah that's what I want because I'm an
American
yeah and I want Bill Clinton put out a
statement today from his publicist
because this is what innocent people do
this is what in I am having my manager
draft a statement right now yeah it says
I have no clue I can imagine my manager
listen he only flies very shitty
airlines he books last minute it's skip
lagged it's a scam he gets off at the
connecting city he's usually in a middle
seat people complain about it they don't
like him it's not good but let's get the
galleys say it's alright Fox News
because I thought that they would you
know be the best you have something
texted it to me my friend texted me the
statement about 15 people have texted me
Clinton state knows nothing I did you
don't understand how many friendships
that this is reinvigorated
scene getting caught yeah child
trafficking mmm so many people that
haven't spoken it so long like man what
are you up to have you been I'm like
good man like are you engaged it looks
like you're engaged like yeah man yeah
it's bringing us all together it's
bringing us all together it's [ __ ]
that's what it should do it's a silver
lining yes some good should come up with
something good should come of this okay
so here's Clinton statement this is his
statement that was made through his
spokesman President Clinton knows
nothing about the terrible crimes
Jeffrey Epstein pleaded guilty to in
Florida some years ago or those or those
which with which he has been recently
charged in New York in 20 2002 and 2003
President Clinton took a total of four
trips on Jeffrey Epstein's airplane
which I don't think is true one to
Europe one to Asia two to Africa which
included stops in connection with the
work of the Clinton Foundation the [ __ ]
what what are they doing you know we're
all supposed to ignore that the guy was
on two pedophiles playing four times oh
no he was doing work with the Clinton
Foundation is there no other plane that
goes to Africa or Asia was that the only
plane yeah it mean it's called the
Lolita Express staff supporters of the
foundation and his Secret Service detail
traveled on every leg of the trip
there are also [ __ ] kids probably
that's probably why they got the job
guarding Clinton yeah they're like you
want to do some parties guard Clinton
yeah look I already tell you those are
children Yeah right yeah you got 12
year-old sipping cocktails serving
cocktails have been pulled their pants
up he had one meeting with em seen in
his Harlem office in 2002 okay why again
this is more questions and okay what are
you talking about and around the same
time made one brief visit to MCS New
York apartment with a staff member and
his security detail he's not smoking I
have seen him well over a decade and has
never been to little st. James Island
Epstein's
to New Mexico or his residence in
Florida I want everyone to realize
what's happening you have an
ex-president of the United States
through his spokesman saying that he has
never been to the pedophile island this
is why yeah yeah this is [ __ ] wild
yeah you have an ex-president going I
was never to who's advising him to put
out a statement yeah I don't know but it
it's not what you do when you're
completely innocent
yeah I'll tell you that much it doesn't
feel like an innocent my father doesn't
have a statement ready to go on this you
know I love that he's never been to the
island where they were [ __ ] the kids
I mean it's him he's gotta clarify yeah
he's like no I stayed downstairs bills
bill bills only been on the thing four
times because they were doing work with
the Clinton Foundation good wholesome
Clinton Foundation work okay yes he was
on the plane yes Epstein was on the
plane yes they were [ __ ] kids but not
bill bill needed a trim needed a ride to
Asia for the Clinton Foundation so he
just went on the plane and he you know
took a xanax and fell right out he
didn't wake up with some 13 years
pushing his mouth not at all not at all
and don't think it you know can we
adjust the Billy Irish thing yeah yeah I
had no idea that that was offensive
it wasn't yeah I don't think it wasn't
can you summarize what we said about
Billy Irish and then there was me I'm K
ultra victim right she looks like she's
been forced to go up there and dance and
looks like I've made a job involved in
Satanism funny things I made a joke
jokes
Harvey want that involve the premise
that Harvey Weinstein was a rapist right
sorry I apologize you're right he's not
been convicted in a court of law so
you're absolutely right about that it
was irresponsible of me to insinuate
based on my best knowledge
that all Harv took advantage of people
in the entertainment industry
specifically women and I made a joke
maybe it was a tasteless joke but that's
what I do that's what we do have they
seen any of the other clips and the the
joke was that this girl who I did not
know was a minor I didn't know she was
mine yeah I didn't know what she was she
could have been 24 she could have been
34 I didn't know I didn't she was
bleeding out of her eyes in the video I
didn't think she was a minor she'd do it
songs about [ __ ] people's dads I
didn't think she was a Shirley Temple I
apologize for not thinking that she was
[ __ ] Shirley Temple she's bleeding
out of her eyes in a video I think I'm
the bad guy I'm the bad guy come get me
so I said she looked like somebody who
kept Harvey wants he kept in a cage and
rape for ten years we put the clip up on
it and then at the end I said I'm Billie
raped me or whatever
I should have warded it maybe
differently because it wasn't as funny
because the Weinstein was funnier and
then the rule is the tags always have to
be funnier than the red and then people
get angry people are Instagram well
Instagram took it off and then people in
the comments were defending Instagram
because people that she's a minor and
you don't know you don't know see again
if you just abduct and rape minors you
get away with that for decades but did
that was up if you make a joke yeah
about a horrible world that we live in
it's down within 24 hours right so
people aren't people would defending
Instagram they're like well I knew this
was gonna be taken down as soon as it
went up because she's a minor and that
was I'm defending the big faceless
corporation isn't Instagram on my
facebook
I'll get people on Facebook
live-streaming their suicides aren't
people checking out in the Christchurch
shooter what did he do on face
didn't he livestream of shooting on
Facebook the Christchurch shooter okay
yeah he live-streamed a terrorist attack
on your platform but he was 18 and older
right he was an adult I'm sorry sorry
for my quip sorry my quip about a
hi millionaire go back to live-streaming
mass death it also kind of makes
Instagram seem Pro Weinstein like you're
trying to you know make a joke about who
these people are at the gram [ __ ] works
at the gram these people think the only
people to get respect are [ __ ] you
know these people
we weren't arafat comedy now poster
selfie [ __ ] yeah we're in an era of
thought comedy duck face empty-headed
retards making faces and it's come [ __ ]
me comedy yeah that's what people do
don't you want to maybe [ __ ] me come see
my show and listen it is what it is
people make money the way they make
money but that's where we are now stop
comedy hmm people want to talk about
people posting real thirst trap photos
of themselves cuz I'm a comedian I'm
funny come get it you know
that's what they're doing and it is what
it is but that's what Instagram would
love everything to be yeah just duckface
thoughts just full of bimbos just full
of people fitness trainers here's how to
make a turkey burger you want to make a
turkey burger I was I'll tell you right
now I was in an uber today with a guy
who had to be 700 pounds at a certain
point
uber has to say no yeah you look like
Israel comical we wall his fat had
spilled from the driver's seat into the
backseat and I was sitting with another
person I thought I took a pool but it
was the rest of him in the back and I'm
not in shape I get it but this was too
much I'm gonna lose weight because fat
now is like this proud identity that I
don't want to be a part of that's why I
have to lose weight I don't want to be
part of like the the fat movement
becoming cool it's becoming this
the cool band and you knew them before
I'm not even ashamed to be on a beach I
should be I'm not even ashamed I'm just
walking around like yeah spatch cuz
that's what it's about now
so I gotta I gotta scale it down I just
I hope and pray you know maybe I'll
become a thot comic I'll just start
posting selfies
hey hey hey my my clip is coming you
ready you ready for my comedy clip yeah
we're in the era you know I had somebody
over the other day and I go just accept
that this is done that the world were
living in is kind of over yeah we're at
the end of humanity we're in the we're
hopefully going to the posthuman era
where this phone will be in your [ __ ]
body within 10 years and we're done we
ran a race it was great
but people don't you know what I want to
be too dark I don't want to be that guy
that depresses everybody now you're
never that guy you know but I just want
to let people know that it's all here
folks we have an ex-president going I
was never on the pedophile Island
can you imagine hey hey hey I was not on
the pedophile Island yeah why it feels
like something in the realm of what
Trump would say like you know like Trump
would actually address it just cuz he
like just says anything I said Clinton I
said it on Twitter this ends with Alex
Jones getting the Medal of Freedom and
we're gonna find out that he was right
about Sandy Hook
we're gonna find that's next by the way
I could see it happening that's next we
find out there never was a Sandy Hook
that's coming mm-hmm and that will not
be the Instagram clip that will not be
the Instagram clip the Instagram clips
just gonna be me talking about how to
make a turkey burger is this ooh the
lean meat
brown rice put it in a bowl you ever
watch the Instagram Fitness people
they're all hot yeah yeah the roll
eight looking yeah they all just take
pictures of themselves all day these
[ __ ] models I follow a few of them
yep
they just sit there putting their tits
in front of French toast I always
comment like one kid they won't they all
wrap it up with like positivity it's
always like one kid was like your face
like you should smile and because your
face let's I'll show you exactly what
this what would happen because I
commented and I will continue by the way
I just want some interaction and none of
these [ __ ] give me the interaction
that I want but do you need help out
there I know you do I know you do I know
each and every one of you need something
you don't know what it is but there's a
clawing feeling like something that
lives inside of you is eating away at
the part of you that matters the only
part of you that matters the part of you
that came alive as a child the part of
you that still believes that things will
be ultimately good a part of you that
believes in love a part of you that
hopes for a better world you believe
that you know you believe that that part
of you is essential to you when you're
correct and as you get older that part
of you wears away little by little every
disappointment every slight every dark
episode of your life kind of makes that
little hopeful inner child scream a
little more and you you lose yourself
you slide into an abyss you can't feel
it happening it's like the nothing you
ever see the neverending story it's a
great film it's about a guy named Atreyu
and he's a UH who gives a [ __ ] what he
is he's rides a horse to a magical land
then it's being eaten and what's eating
it then nothing
that's what's heating it not some big
evil character not Donald Trump okay the
nothing just the absence of good the
absence of anything is just eating and a
trailer loses his horse in the swamps of
sadness it's very it's a great [ __ ]
movie and then there's a big rock
creature and then there's also a big
turtle named Orla
and the turtle says one of my favorite
things ever they go do you care and the
turtle goes we don't care whether or not
we care that's what it's about you see
what I mean folks that's what it is
answer questions with that I don't care
what the question is start looking at
people look them right in the eye and go
we don't care whether or not we care
that's it
the nothing is eating you and there's
nothing you can really do about it
you're wrong you're wrong you can go to
better help calm / Tim Dylan okay better
help us online counseling it's here for
you they offer licensed professional
counselors who specialized in issues
like depression stress anxiety
relationships sleeping anger family
conflicts self-esteem and more better
help lets you connect with your
professional accounts are in a safe and
private online environment anything you
share is confidential if you're not
happy you can switch at any time to
another therapist
you can schedule should secure video or
phone sessions plus chat and text with
your therapist ok you can switch let no
additional charge I don't remember how
would try you betta nothin I don't
remember I also don't remember believing
that he did I thought the nothing was
kind of gonna win but I don't think it
did at the end maybe it did it should
have I think because it was looking very
you know but it's a movie so they but I
don't want the nothing to win we all
battle against our own death I'm trying
to think how he say it's the luckdragon
had a big part it's Al Gore that big dog
okay that huge dog who was a white dog
big white luck track was not a dog it's
a furry dragon he helped defeat the
nothing I don't know how because enough
things seem very formidable and then
this kind of happy dumb big puppet
flying around it's like well if that was
could we have done that earlier in the
film why I don't know maybe the rock
creature had something I don't know what
happened I want to watch the film again
my point is this okay
the nothing doesn't have to win you
don't have a luck dragon you don't have
a big fluffy white dog and if you do
you're a racist you're a Nazi but what
you do have is a great online counseling
service called better help 10% off your
first month by going to better health
calm slash Jim Dylan TI m di ll o n why
not get started today better help calm
/t IM d i ll o n simply fill out a
questionnaire to help them assess your
needs and get matched with a
professional counselor that you'll love
I'm just looking at the ending a never
ending story here because I don't I I
personally want to understand what
happened at the end um let's let's just
see here at the end ah uh so here's the
plot at the end of the movie I don't
want to ruin it but I'm gonna ruin it uh
the Empress tells Bastion that he has
the power to bring back Fantasia within
his imagination well this is Bastion
recreates Fantasia as he flies on FAL
course back yeah that's what it's all
about and then he sees the land and its
inhabitants restored this movie's
[ __ ] and that Atreyu has been
reunited with our attacks the horse that
died in the swamps of sadness when
Falkor asked what his next wish will be
Bastion then brings Falkor back to the
real world to chase down the bullies
from before the film ends with the
narration that Bastion has had many more
wishes and adventures and adds but
that's another story
so falkor the luckdragon comes into the
real world because the kids being
bullied and he scares the bullies yeah I
mean listen folks it's not the Godfather
okay let's start with
trying to help you out better help I do
like the nothing now I do find that a
fitting metaphor and I do like that we
don't care the quote from the big turtle
okay and I do like to rock creature and
I do like the neverending story too
because it was an acid river and very
shiny metal and glass boats and I kind
of liked the idea of that if somebody
fell in the river they would burn up I
kind of like I like if they did
something like that in Orange County
something like very shiny and deadly
like that I think that's it
better help.com / Tim - thank you
goodbye
is your uncle Stan who I love on social
media at all know who is uncle Stan cuz
this guy I have to meet this guy he's my
gay 83 year old unofficial uncle who
just kind of like became friends with my
mom which was pregnant with me and just
forced his way into my life and called
himself my uncle and I would spend
summers in his antiques shop and he
would take me to plays and and he's been
banned from tons of restaurants he's
just super sassy and mean and hates
women and and just talks to anybody
about their sex life I have to meet this
[ __ ] guy so it would be amazing this
is the guy that I have to meet because
this guy seems like a guy that you know
you might be you know aging into him
yeah I'm gonna age in if I'm lucky why
does he get banned from all these
restaurants just he speaks like he
thinks he's half Mexican but he just
looks like Jack Nicholson but he thinks
like it comes like it comes across the
people that he's like Hispanic and he'll
speak really bad Spanish to people and
say horrible things like you know oh
your boy was probably [ __ ] some other
girl right he's crazy you see that a
restaurant he had a restaurant
god bless this [ __ ] guy maybe at the
grocery store and he'll be he'll be
talking to the guy checking him out like
how's your sex life Juan do you [ __ ]
good and he'll like gesture like a [ __ ]
gesture are you [ __ ] while you're
[ __ ] good Juan is recessed yes the
[ __ ] everybody yeah he'll be really
racist - hosts at restaurants they don't
seat him quick like he look like I'm a
diabetic [ __ ] you better seat me
I'll call the Better Business Bureau on
you he's always threatening to call the
Better Business Bureau he'll say that
he's he'll ask them what their ethnicity
hasn't been where are you from and
they'll be like El Salvador and him like
oh they'll Salvadorians they're all
users dude we're gonna get a shirt that
says I'm a diabetic [ __ ] that's
coming so if you're into the merch I am
a diabetic [ __ ] is coming I got
Omega people people that don't start
trouble in restaurants I can't
understand them I don't even want to be
near somebody who's not been in an
altercation in a restaurant they're not
my people at all my mother was like that
my mother God love her she is in a
institution but my mother we used to go
out to dinner every meal cuz she didn't
cook and they didn't try to manage their
money they just thought you went out to
eat
that's what trash people think you do
when you have money okay like I remember
one chick that I went to school with
real trash pick and she would go out to
like Fridays all the time this was like
a few years maybe after college somebody
commented oh you go out to eat a lot and
she just goes yeah it's part of my
lifestyle and that's what trash people
think and that's the way I've lived my
life when you're trash you think going
out to a restaurant is because literally
the only people who can't do it are
homeless people so you're above them
you're like above the homeless and
that's where you know yeah like look at
me so my mother used to go out and she
would order the special and she would
always order it like it'd be a fish
special and she'd be like let's get it
without the sauce and without any of the
vets like I just want the fish on the
plate with butter which already chefs
don't like and she'd go I like some
french fries lightly cooked and then the
French fries would come and they
wouldn't really be lightly cooked my
mother would call the waitress over and
these people know her so they all had
PTSD and my mother would go hey let me
ask you a question do these french fries
look lightly cooked to you do they do
they look like it would be great like a
question you answer she never just got
to the complaint it was she turned it
into a courtroom let me ask you a
question do these french fries to you
maybe I'm wrong do they look lightly
cooked
and then the waitress would go ah I
guess not that not that lightly cooks my
mother would go right let me ask you
another question if the chef back there
can't figure out how to make french
fries do you think he's in the right
line of work so now my mother is led her
into this and the ladies like I don't
know and then one I swear to God one
time the lady said the my mother he's
had a really rough time I think he's
wife is sick
it's really tough I think it's wife it's
cancer my mother goes well I assume the
meal is free and that those are the
people I want to be around yeah I want
to be around people that get so angry in
a restaurant they start to look like
they're gonna get physically violent you
know yeah that's what I like that five
Easy Pieces saying yeah that kind of
like broke the barrier for treating
waiters like pieces of [ __ ] waiters and
I don't mean this in a derogatory way
waiters often are pieces of [ __ ]
yeah that's not not always but in some
cases waiters and waitresses should be
tortured because and I know that there's
a lot of them they're gonna email and
tweet and call but yet I understand it's
so yeah get another job okay
this is my only happiness did you go to
swingers again I did tell you right now
that same lady there no she was probably
home god only knows doing god only knows
what trying to make her dreams come true
by the way the waitresses at swingers
all look like thirteen-year-old Epstein
like chicks that were kicked off the
plane before they took off it looks like
I've seen line them up wait no no no you
go serve hummus in West Hollywood you're
out you're out the pedophile dodgeball
game is what it looks like
children yeah in [ __ ] swingers dumb
diner the problem West Coast diners is
you don't have you need diner people I'm
a diner person yeah
let's close people is like cool people
in the diner you don't want cool people
in a diner right you want people that
are like that's your home mm-hmm that's
their home hmm
my mother acted my mother would sit for
hours in a diner because she didn't want
to come home to her loveless marriage so
that's her home and you better treat her
like that you better bring that stuff
flounder yeah and it better be exactly
what she wanted and if not you know my
waitresses would sit in the booth and
talk to my mother
mm-hmm you know but I mean swingers is
just these people that are like have you
made a decision yeah I've made a
decision I've made a decision to shoot
up this restaurant doing like an
impression of a diner you know like
those fake 50s diners [ __ ] like that
yeah it's like yeah Norm's this is what
eating french toast was like during
segregation enough enough with you [ __ ]
it
Marvin in the [ __ ] lives of 50s diner
waitress is that we're [ __ ] competent
by the way because if they weren't they
got a boot to the face from Epstein to
diners these are all problems these are
all issues had a file cults the death of
the diner yeah all problems I want to
talk about this too because I did your
stand-in marry a courtyard and the
Marriott at one time is one of my
favorite hotels can someone shut that
dog up Emma stop Emma enough what are
you nervous - were you on the plane I
stayed in the Marriott Courtyard what is
your favorite hotel chain
I like Holiday Inn when I've been there
like this sweets or whatever I mean the
sweets I don't know the Express suite
even to make stress sweets get how much
I don't you know the Express Express get
in Oklahoma they had a big Continental
back
a lot of fat people it was nice I liked
being around it Mary it used to be the
gold standard for hotels in this [ __ ]
country because they were Mormon Mormons
are clean disciplined people they have
irrational beliefs but who cares they
don't drink they don't smoke they keep
it clean they keep it efficient they
keep it moving
they had a great hotel the Marriot they
had a Marriott nice breakfast buffet my
mother used to take me to the breakfast
buffet it was a nice thing that we did
on Sundays now somebody is convinced
Mary Mary's bought like every hotel they
own like 35 million hotel chains now
someone is now convinced Mary it instead
of having a real restaurant in the hotel
and room service
they now have something called Bistro to
go Bistro to go is like a partner with
Starbucks it's a glorified Starbucks
where you can get food that was it's
preheated in a bag and put in a box a
cardboard box and delivered to your room
like you're in one of those detention
centers on the border that's what you
feel like when you get it hmm I just
don't know what happened hmm I don't
know what happened yeah and these new
modern hotels that want to make
everything modern that's not what you
want in a hotel that's what you want in
an apartment I want a nice warm homey
feeling I want a real restaurant I want
a nice buffet
I want an angry Asian chef making
omelets who's a woman who's very
efficient and very angry that's who I
want I don't want a glorified [ __ ]
Starbucks I don't want to eat out of a
[ __ ] box okay our hotels not doing
room service like anymore really turning
into like an Amazon Prime delivery of
like some [ __ ] I almost I got I went to
a hotel once I ordered room service and
then they said okay to the front desk
you could pick it up and I said no no no
no
it is room service on the phone it says
room service doesn't say desk service it
says you bring it to my room if I was
gonna leave my room I'll just leave the
property the food isn't good I'm paying
a huge premium for mediocre [ __ ] then
I'm gonna eat in my room
well I watched YouTube or whatever else
then go nuts at the desk I said the hell
it is please bring it up and they said
it's at the desk and I screamed as loud
as I could into the phone I am a
paraplegic I am a [ __ ] paraplegic and
there was silence on the guess what
knock on the door with my food and I
don't know if even the room service
person knew that I was a paraplegic but
they probably did they were probably
like you gotta bring this up to this and
I open the door and they saw me and they
looked at my legs and I just looked at
them I grab the food now what I'm cured
and I shut the door
that's all we're not [ __ ] around
anymore we're not [ __ ] around anymore
we're demanding service at the Marriott
Courtyard we're demanding service we're
demanding the conviction of child
rapists and with demanding service at
the Marriott Courtyard we're not gonna
[ __ ] around it's not a class issue stop
with this oh yeah it's not a class issue
it's an issue of service it's an issue
of pride take pride in your job yeah I
have a lot of pride in my job I say
great things about comedy comedians all
the time you know yeah what do a
Marriott Courtyard on this road trip and
they didn't even have free coffee in the
lobby they like have a Starbucks and you
think it's free but then it's just the
Starbucks is invaded everything
everything was just Starbucks there's
er's now with a Starbucks in them go get
a Frappuccino while you wait for surgery
yeah maybe we don't need everything to
be this country's a big [ __ ]
Starbucks soon as Starbucks starts
selling guns there'll be no reason to go
anywhere else
in this country yeah the drive-throughs
are everywhere too
I can't wait for the Epstein trial when
they start to shame the victims you know
that's coming yeah you know some some
defense attorneys gonna be like okay um
I guess it's time to hear from these
hoes maybe some of these hoes can get up
on they're gonna they gonna you gonna
tell us some story
beep be one of the girls ok hello in
your name your name state your name for
the record
Jessica hi Jessica are you aware of the
defendant you know the defendant yeah
yes you do huh yeah you know Jeff yeah I
do
he point him out uh right there yeah
honey right there he gave you ride on
his plane he did oh he did huh yes did
you pay for that ride I did not she was
a free ride on its plane I guess you
took a free ride on the plane Jessica
huh yeah do you know how much fuel costs
I got a 737 I I do not you have no idea
now if you just wore it on the put did
he force you to get on the plane I um I
don't think snow so you just got on the
plane and you got and you took a trip he
said we were just taking a trip
vacation and you went to a private
island yes yeah so let me get this
straight
you took a free trip to a private island
okay on my clients dime and the only
thing you had to do was suck Alan
Dershowitz his old [ __ ] have you ever
sat middle seat on a Spirit Airlines
flight Jess I do you know how many [ __ ]
I'd put my mouth to never do that
hey did you have your own seat on the
plane Jessica oh you did huh dad your
own seat you had your own room on the
plane didn't you had a bed I yeah oh you
had a bed I was tied up but yeah okay
because of turbulence because of
turbulence I didn't think of and all you
had to do was take a few loads from the
leader of the free world Rhodes Scholar
do you know could the economy
when President Clinton was in Jessica do
you have any idea I was very young I
don't write so the mastermind of one of
the greatest boom times ever wanted to
empty a few loads on your tummy in a
private chat and suddenly the world owes
you something I hey hey [ __ ] are you
serious right now
look at this jury of poor people are you
see they've never been to an island they
went to sandals once like a Tiffany
Haddish is the lawyer you know she will
be in the movie big sketch yeah but you
know that's gonna go down yeah yeah
it'll be like we're you know reverse
Kavanaugh these are all so fun but none
of them could ever go on social media
you gotta listen to the podcast folks
you gotta listen because we cannot take
the chance of putting these things up
because they're coming for us we were on
a list
we've been shadow band somebody who
follows me goes I look you up you're 6
and I follow you you come up like six
shadow band hmm wonderful
don't get nervous I know you're an
industry guy Devin's got a lot of
industry friends make him nervous
oh you sit next to Tim Dylan he's going
off are you ever uncomfortable on the
show with what I said never know
honestly I've given up I don't that's
the thing wait a minute wait hold on you
don't want to be on a game show on truTV
that's not your goal I mean I'm missing
out on writing for a snapchat comedy
series that requires a password and a IP
address - whoa but me and Ben at a
meeting today we walk into guys like
guys
you know we can't really put this on
like NBC I go yeah he goes no he goes
maybe Comedy Central TBS talking about
the desk videos I'm like yeah I don't
even think they're really but who knows
let it happen unless they completely
change the format of their channels and
like what they believe in I don't I
don't see it happening I mean what Frank
TV you guys know funny how incredibly
scared we are of speech and jokes how we
don't give a [ __ ] about people's actions
you don't really care about people's
actions no we don't give a [ __ ] about
that we care about what you say you know
there's videos on Instagram with people
punching kids I'm sure and they have so
many views the but yeah I'm gonna take
them off I mean all those Instagram
Fitness people like these hot dudes that
I follow I comment all the time they're
like your face is so important always
try to smile because that you know
that's that shows the world how you feel
inside and I'll be like I'll just
comment like what if the bear ate your
face how do I smile then I was mauled by
a bear I don't have a face I used to
drink at a bar called the helm there was
a guy Lou he had no nose was the hole in
the middle of his face we called him
Louie no nose and you know what no
matter how happy he was or how much he
grinned the world was very troubled by
the way he presented I don't I think
he's sniffed so much cocaine II lost his
nose I don't know sometimes I just want
to be that hot guy who just takes
pictures on the beach in Malibu
I just puts dumb quotes up you know Live
Love Laugh yeah you know believe in
yourself forget about the drama you
don't need the drama be yourself don't
let anybody tell you that you're less
than know let everyone tell you you're
less than you're less than you are less
than there are people that are more than
and by definition you're less but that's
the thing you send all these people into
the world thinking they're beautiful
thinking they're intelligent and they're
informed and they're 450 pounds and they
go into the world and they've learned
everything off a Twitter thread and they
open their dumb mouths I'm sitting at
dinners with some people who open their
mouths and they just start
and they don't know what they're saying
and I'm like shut up go back into a cave
learn and then come out again oh these
people hopping on the epstein train
where were you guys right where the [ __ ]
were you when I was talking about this
Mullen was talking about Luis Gomez not
really but sometimes you know loosely
Geoffrey was a dentist he was trying to
get free [ __ ] from Adam doesn't matter
what matters is we were there all these
people that are now jumping on the train
like they know what the [ __ ] going on
yeah super convenient to know I can't
wait till how we end will end this
somehow and make Geoffrey I've seen a
hero I don't know how we're gonna do it
we'll make him a hero yeah he looks like
he could be good I want to hear from him
he hasn't spoken yeah I do want to hear
him talk I want to hear from him yeah I
want to hear him I want to hear what
he's got to say
let me look like a Gayle King interview
like our Kelly did ya yell King just
sits there she's always talking to
rapists yeah like her favorite thing to
do kill kings trying to get raped
that's why Kings like can you show me
exactly how you did it somebody how
would you hold them down why don't you
just cut off my airflow just can I ask
you a question Geoffrey can you choke me
would you mind cutting off my air flow
with your big bare hand just so I could
experience what the girls experienced
and I will then make a decision if this
is rape or not just put your hand on my
neck no I see the film guys getting
nervous no no he's gonna choke me he's
gonna choke me now what names are gonna
come up what would shock you know Woody
Allen's gonna probably come up maybe I
feel like he's more of a lone like he
did that on his own he's like well he
was friends with Epstein there oh yeah
they lived around a block from each
other I wouldn't know if it's really the
Chris Tucker cuz I'm saying it's not
it's another Chris Tucker that's that's
actually I like that I don't want Chris
I don't want Chris talker involved you
know
I want people I hate implicated I have a
whole list of people yeah that I want
implicate and you say who they are no
well maybe I but there's a whole list of
people that I don't feel like I've done
me right that I want implicated I want
them to have to explain why they were at
the island mm-hmm can't explain it
some people gonna have to explain that
it's gonna be hilarious people are gonna
be like you know I knew Jeffrey but I
didn't really know him and he's like hey
I got an island I like the water so I
was like I wanna take a vacation there
was a lot of kids around pay attention
to it I didn't know was going on then
there was this weird temple where the
kids would massage I saw but I thought
it was for UNICEF like I thought this
was some type of fundraiser I throws it
for the Red Cross
I don't know yeah and then afterwards
we'd hunt these children we would get in
groups of three I would put numbers on
the children and then hunt them and this
was all part of the Boys and Girls Club
that's what they said this is we sponsor
children so we have to in order to see
which child we sponsor we had to hunt
them and then shoot them with a dart gun
that again that is what it was it was
for the boys girls club a lot of people
are like are you making fun of this yep
make fun of it cuz we're living in hell
we're making fun of hell and all of
these people should go to jail and be
killed
yeah don't [ __ ] email me and tweeted
me and be like you're making light of it
put them in jail put Bill Clinton in
jail you know yeah these people are if
they're doing and we know they are doing
that there's zero [ __ ] chance that
Bill Clinton and that we was not [ __ ]
underage chicks on that plan there's no
chance nobody believes that not even
Hillary you know they were both tweeting
about soccer the other day how proud
they were of the soccer team mm-hmm yeah
that's what they're talking about what
you have focused on soccer you know
Hillary was like I mean
the people close to them that's what
that's a dark job their handlers their
assistants they know there's blood in
the water they [ __ ] know man and they
got to come out with these dumb [ __ ]
statements it was never on the island
these people got it and they and they
sleep very well they all sleep great and
they're aiding and abetting some of the
worst crimes unimaginable crimes and
they're because these are crime families
the Clanton's the bushes they are crime
family and the Trump's to a degree are
krotz this is criminal activity I don't
know what Donald Trump was involved in
or what he wasn't involved in but I do
know a lot of the [ __ ] he's done with
his real estate connections he's been
involved with very shady characters you
know these are people that get to where
they get because they commit crimes and
they get away with it and I know that's
hard for people to believe because they
like they in their head they believe
that these people are talented but
Clinton is a brilliant politician you
know Trump's talented they have talents
but they're also criminals and many of
them are child rapists and murderers so
you know you can be a lot of things you
don't have to be any one thing but
people got to open their mind a little
bit do you think like this opens up a
conversation about who these people are
because that is what I'd really like to
see happen yeah and I don't think it
will now I don't think it will I think
we'll move past it yeah because it's a I
don't know I just I feel like people are
it's too heavy it's like too much it's
too much dude do you think there will be
any kids that like we find out like 10
11 like kid kids
yeah even likes it gonna be bad when
that comes out that's gonna get [ __ ]
really really scary if you're if you're
just not you're okay with the 13 fair
enough
what
you know when Russ Baker wrote that book
family of secrets and and I read it and
he described the process of writing it
and he said to me and Raycom the great
read Kampf he said when I started to
really understand who these people are
and how they operated the book and the
process of writing it had the profundity
of theology meaning it was so profound
it was a religious experience I started
to understand things that I net that
never made any sense to me that started
to make sense all of these questions
that I had about why things operated a
certain way they started to become more
clear as I understood who these people
were and also as I understood all the
influences and the pressures that were
exerted on them how some of them had
been blackmailed some of them owe their
political career to you know a certain
billionaire a certain power broker that
these people had been party to criminal
acts that were then covered up and the
people that facilitated that coverup
were able to use that and leverage power
and pull strings and he goes once you
start seeing how all of that happens
it's it's clear to you that that dumb
remember School of Rock it's like how
bill becomes a law I'm just a bill
sitting here on Capitol Hill and you
read that I mean you watch that I mean
like oh that's what happens the house
legislation originates there goes to the
Senate then it goes to the president
that's not really it that's a very
positive way of looking at how things
get done you know have you seen that I'm
just a bill yeah yeah back and everybody
has seen that mm-hmm that's not what it
is no it's not what it is it's like I'm
just do bill I was sponsored by a
senator he [ __ ] a kid in a hotel in
Washington there was a camera there and
someone sent that photo to him
and now he said we need a war we're
gonna have a war and they said you're
gonna have three more Wars he said okay
don't tell them I [ __ ] the kid and I'm
just a bill
I was written with blood I'm just a bill
I was written with blood I go to the
house then the Senate floor there were
cameras at that party they so you [ __ ]
that hall and I'm just a bill and I
think that's what it really is we killed
the Kennedy we put Michael Hastings went
through a tree I'm just a bill don't
look at me I'm just a bill we had a
debate
it wasn't about rape that's the chopped
and screwed version so chopped and
screwed version you know that's great
that's what it really is yeah it's not
[ __ ] people haven't you know well I
think you know who I really want to be
on this plane Acacio Cortez
I want to cost you Cortez to come out
and go yeah I [ __ ] those old white
[ __ ] I [ __ ] them and I don't feel
bad about it I [ __ ] him and I stole
their wallets and I took that cash they
give it to the poor the Bronx I want to
have him a moment with her like how she
does was like three to five minute clip
yeah where she just gets out and you
know the phones are on her and she's
like we're about to go viral [ __ ]
mm-hmm she's like yeah I [ __ ] up seen
he's they said he has a weird little
dick like an egg-shaped penis a tiny
egg-shaped penis oh and I want her to be
like I put that old egg in my [ __ ]
mouth I knew exactly what I was doing
that billionaire [ __ ] I went in there I
[ __ ] them all Alan Dershowitz ate my
ass and you know as he was eating my ass
you know what I was doing I was reading
Marx and getting ready for the war I
used my sexuality as a weapon against
those old [ __ ] i infiltrated that
island that's great it would be great it
would be powerful you see that video of
her being confused about whatever
garbage disposal is she was pretending
she didn't she didn't know what a
garbage disposal yeah but I think she's
she's someone who I thought was gonna be
President now the more I see her I'm
like yeah she needs to stop talking as
much she might be on a reality show in a
few years but that might be the
president that is the presidency all
right I I want there's gonna be one girl
that comes out and is his pro Epstein
like one of the kids that he votes yeah
he's gonna come out like Stockholm
Syndrome and one girl's gonna come out
but they were nice to us
there was always breakfasts you [ __ ]
are crazy Jeff on the other side of this
remember me I'm not selling you out like
the rest of these stank ass hos I'm with
you Jeff does he have kids as I've seen
enough kids it's gotta be a fun date huh
well my dad my dad's actually in the
news right now daddy
bill was not on the island bill feel
barely knows Jeff it was on his playing
four times he had a small meeting in
Harlem 2002 what was that meeting about
farm subsidies is that what they were
discussing in Clinton's office in Harlem
was that what it was talking about trade
I wonder if I've seen his kids yes he
has kids in another way is another type
of kids it's a bad Google search apple
podcast pulls us off what are you doing
that will happen in 20 years you'll have
a pro pedophile podcast yeah absolutely
yeah absolutely
Pro pedophile podcast it's coming okay
good folks when I was a child I was I
was rightly told I had a lot of promise
I was told I was very bright I was told
that I was going to be uh lucky and that
my luck was going to be earned and that
I was going
special I was going to be different I
stood apart from the pack many of you
were not told that and that's because
that is not the case
for many of you many of you are not
special you're not different you don't
matter many of you and I don't mean you
don't matter in a in a grand historic
sense of course you don't I mean even in
the day to day horrible life you have of
your meaningless interactions your
stupid job I mean most of you out there
what are you really doing nothing you're
sucking up air you're using resources
than other people like myself like cardi
B like Donald Trump could be using to
further our agendas because we are
special yes I am sorry I am sorry people
like myself cardi B who I believe her
real name is Bell Calise and Donald
Trump are special people what do we
share me Carter beam Donald Trump
what are we share we're all magnetic
we're all funny effortlessly we all have
a certain sex appeal we've all maybe
drugged people and taking things from
things they didn't need okay they don't
need it here's another thing that unites
me cardi B and Donald Trump we're all
New Yorkers
[ __ ] yeah okay
we're better than you [ __ ] yeah that's
right and we all have [ __ ] web sites
we've got web sites people can look us
up they can see our [ __ ] we got
schedules we got content we got links we
got text video pictures okay
you want a website you want to be like
us you wouldn't be like Donald Trump
cardi B or Tim Dylan two people who got
to start from a reality show one person
got to start from the world of stand-up
comedy go to Wix okay
we built a great site Tim Dylan's going
to hell calm using Wix there is no is
it's just Tim Dylan's going to hell calm
it was incredibly easy to do if you have
a business or content you want to
promote you're missing out on potential
clients and customers if people can only
contact you via social media you you
know you think then it's all on the gram
it's all on Tik Tok wake the [ __ ] up
okay what are you selling your product
to fifteen year olds what are you doing
there's adults out there they want to
read some goddamn testimonials about -
[ __ ] you're peddling you're a [ __ ]
hairstylist people want to know they
want to see photos of things you've done
before they go and plunk down money at
your [ __ ] salon your wedding
photographer maybe you're a DJ they want
to hear that Brenda from Bay Shore Long
Island thought you were great she was a
little skeptical upfront because you
looked Filipino and she didn't really
understand if those people knew about
music but he won me over
that's what Brenda's testimonial would
say I was nervous in front up front
because Dan looked like a Pacific
Islander however I realized then he was
really great and he was great wedding DJ
now my marriage is over but that has
nothing to do with Dan my husband turned
out to be a little abusive I should have
maybe
not coming I did not we have a divorce
that's been playing out in the courts
right now it's unique in the sense that
neither of us want the children we're
dividing up a collection of beanie
babies right now that we inherited from
Dan's mother and we're living in his
mother's basement at Bayshore New York
when we eat bacon egg and cheese
sandwiches and watch Fox News every day
and get ready for the great war with
Donald Trump will lead us into battle
so one thing we still agree on is that
we love Trump we would have got divorced
years ago except that we have that we
still have that you need a testimonial
on the website no matter what you do you
might be a child acting coach and you'd
need somebody to go he never [ __ ] my
kid this guy did not come over and do
creepy [ __ ] he just taught this person
how to act
he didn't come over and do weird [ __ ]
start doing weird breathing exercises on
the floor we were waiting for that but
he was pretty on the level you know we
appreciate that did not [ __ ] the kid now
that my kid has also not gotten any work
I don't know if that's related but I
hope that that all evens out eventually
but these are testimony these are what
boomers want to read before they sign on
for your services okay
my daughter got her hair done with
Jackie de jiggly Oh at Mirage salon in
Massapequa before the prom my daughter
was so happy with the highlights that
Jackie put in that made my little girl
looked like a real Long Island woman she
went to that prom she danced around
putting a puss
everybody's face and we were proud as a
family really proud of her she's very
happy and now she wants to be a stylist
at that same salon so she's smartly not
going to college and she's gonna go
sweep up hair in Massapequa and watch
Jackie make other girls beautiful these
are the types of things you need on the
website so go to Wix they have a
drag-and-drop design system if you don't
want to design your own website Jackie
to dig Leo did not design her own
website
she used Wix ad I artificial design
intelligence she was drunk she tried to
figure out the website she just arted
screaming the n-word and punching her
Mac that's not the move finally somebody
said Jackie just just use the ADI and
she did and now she's getting a lot more
people coming into her salon over 150
million people have built their website
using Wix who cares is that even a lot
of people I don't know these are these
dumb things were supposed to read 150
million people does that matter Tim no
one's going to help calm click the link
at the bottom to get 10% off any Wix
premium plan okay don't be one of these
people that doesn't have a website be
like me be like Donald Trump be like
cardi B we are better than you [ __ ]
cuz we have websites and because we were
chosen by Christ to lead humanity to the
next level cardi B Tim Dylan Donald
Trump no one else goodbye
how long have we done 48 yeah it would
be great if we found out some like
people who we were just completely
shocked by were on that plane you know
you know I don't want to talk about this
anymore like the the [ __ ] to the kids
but we can't stop I've tried to stop for
two years it's every every news story
exciting but every news story is this
yeah and then you get mad at some of the
conspiracy people
because you're like everything's not
everyone's a pedophile and then you turn
on the news and you're like well I guess
actually hmm actually actually maybe you
guys are right who's that it's just a
random voice but I I wonder thank God we
have comment County will save us don't
you think don't you think stand-up
comedy will save us don't you think all
we really need to undo the power the
Pittock recei is a good a good old bit
mm-hmm
just the perfect bit yeah I remember
these idiots when Louie the hole Louie
first thing happened like the real
comedy loyalists were like he's gonna
come up with the perfect bit and it'll
make it all okay and I'm like guys why
don't you sober up why don't you sit the
[ __ ] down and get some sleep
okay take a nap yeah yeah he'll have
some great pits it won't be the perfect
pit that makes everything okay if it is
I'll be amazed and God love yeah yeah
yeah a bit could save the world you know
what do you do if you're abstain what's
your move take a I don't know take a
plea deal that gives me like nine months
or something I think it's 45 years he
can't run right because then he can't
give any can't doesn't help still
they'll kill him yeah yeah yeah they're
trying to kill him a ratty Hillary
Clinton's in Palm Beach with a crossbow
[Laughter]
you know she's paying off some prison
guard and in New York where he is right
now to go shank him you [ __ ] nuts
they don't want their legacy to be
ruined
feels like I'm just a regular rapist
okay I'm I've just been credibly accused
of rape by of age people can that be my
legacy can my legacy be locking up black
people for no reason and and rape of a
appropriately aged women thank you is
that too much to ask nobody wants that
legacy no you know yeah no yeah they'll
play the most danger mom must be going
crazy Bev must be [ __ ] she and she's
in Hawaii right now but I'm sure she's
not even having fun anymore she's just
on the computer just going off about I
liked everything mom she's [ __ ]
plugged in very plugged in she's plugged
the [ __ ] ins an inside job sandy hook
didn't happen she knows all the family's
names she'll talk about other actors
it's insane
beautiful do we do a live podcast with
listen to me from Jeffery Epstein's like
New York City townhouse like outside of
it do I fly us all to New York that we
just sit outside of Jeffery Epstein's
townhouse yeah why not we get removed
probably you know I wanted to do one buy
at Camp hero in Montauk buy the stranger
things but also [ __ ] stranger things
I've had enough of that yeah hey enough
of that are like older now hey enough
enough no one cares
stop with this nostalgia you're rolling
some odd nostalgia hi yep for the 80s
even Spielberg [ __ ] you know that you
know the 80s was uh AIDS and crack for a
lot of people I know you lily-white
[ __ ] think the 80s was all about
malls and carnivals but for a lot of
people the AIDS was about watching your
friend waste away because he had a
disease the government wouldn't say is
true or watching mom light a rock in
your living room because the CIA was
selling it to her I want to see that
stranger things episode where's the
stranger things episode where Wynonna
riders smoking crack and she doesn't
give a [ __ ] about the demagogue on
anymore yeah she doesn't care about the
alien she's like well you kids shut the
[ __ ] up about this alien and she just
smacks him right across the face and she
just likes a rock
[Laughter]
that episode was the wheel where's the
savings and loan scandal where they all
lose their [ __ ] houses and Wynonna
riders [ __ ] smoking crack in a car
that they're all living in hopper hopper
has AIDS cuz he's sucking [ __ ] and not
telling anyone about it
he's a leather daddy he's doing
intravenous drugs
let's get nostalgic for real [ __ ] okay
it's not all hanging out in the mall and
fighting some alien yeah okay [ __ ]
clowns make a real show about crack and
AIDS it was a tease show with some fun
music behind people were doing blow yeah
Wynonna rider would have been sniffing
her [ __ ] face off in that kitchen
numb mouth barely speak shana the kids
like mom what happened to my piggy bank
shut up I'm going out mom's going out
she joins the Dallas buyers club Sid
Wolford that character turns around to
the other kid he's like mom smoking it
now it's getting bad it's getting bad
she doesn't have any money anymore so
she's smoking it that should be the
alien why not arrived by the way before
she got stranger things were shoplifting
right she was stealing [ __ ] from [ __ ]
Bloomingdale's yeah I don't like that
show
I mean listen it's one of those things
where it should have been a movie
90-minute movie
I enjoyed it when it first came on
mm-hmm we don't need 9 seasons of
everything we don't need to see these
kids but grow up to be in their 30s no
one gives a [ __ ] okay you still fighting
the same alien and not for ready the
upside down what is the upside down you
know I don't I watched the first season
that was a like the wall was like the
monster or something right it's based on
the mantra project it's based on
something that actually happened and I
you know I get it but again we
you know pair base it on by the way
marlboro lights sponsored the show
Barbara lights do not just for
substitute teachers who want to die you
ever see your sub smoking I used to do
coke of my sub my sub was a real Italian
real [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and she used to do
we used to come over to coke house and
get a couple of bags her and her husband
used to probably load up and [ __ ] each
other like like animals then she'd come
in the next day with 15 circles under
her eyes look like a raccoon
drinking coffee she put on a video and
go sit in the back she was still coming
down she was a good woman I miss her I
miss those people they're good people
we're gonna wrap it up here folks
we've taken down enough sacred cows it's
a good show people people are really
enjoying this they're enjoying it
because we're careful that's what this
society is full of too many fat people
running their mouth this show is about
people that are careful and cautious and
that believe in this country this is a
great land
this is a great country that we live in
and everything that we've gotten we've
all learned and it's all been honest
that's why people like the show they
like the show because finally somebody
who's proud to live in a country run by
satanic pedophiles black magic Wizards
corrupt Pluto
rats oligarchs literal demons they're
proud we're proud we're not gonna we're
not gonna apologize for who we are
no we just celebrated the 4th of July
fourth of July and then a few days later
our ex-president told us that he wasn't
on the pedophile Island happy fourth of
July
isn't that nice everyone oh say can you
see I was only on the plane four times I
never went to the island we had a quick
meeting in Harlem and the crimes that he
did all the [ __ ] of kids was not
involved with my Clinton Foundation work
oh say I am innocent of the tweener
I only raped Juanita Broderick and she
enjoyed it no matter what she said and
then the f-15s just fly over super ball
starts Tim de la comédie calm folks I
will be coming to hilarities in
Cleveland July 19th to 20th August 1st
through the 3rd American comedy Co in
San Diego the 4th 5th 6th 7th I'm down
at Zanies in Nashville comedy zone in
Charlotte I'm a stand-up live in Hudson
Huntsville Alabama stardome in Hoover
Alabama I'm a good night's comedy club
in late August in North Carolina Tim Jay
Dylan TI ll oh and on Instagram and
Twitter follow me there shadow banning
us we got to get ahead of us we're
independent now on the podcast the
patreon is coming to patreon we'll have
all the archives two and a half years of
Tim Dylan's going to hell every
interview that we did all the conspiracy
stuff russ Baker Nick Bryan who took
Johnny Mark Kelly Adi talking about
Russia all this great [ __ ] really
interesting stuff deep dives on all of
those [ __ ] things
we're gonna go to twice a week you know
when we launched a patreon you'll get an
episode a week on the first tier on the
second tier you'll get all those
archives and an episode a week the third
tier will be crazy you're gonna get
longer videos in the desc things that we
do you'll get an email to correspond
with the show you can suggest topics and
rants and whatever you know maybe you'll
come on for interviews where we're open
to that too
we're really moving ahead it's really
gonna be fun it's really gonna be crazy
and wild we're really off the chain hmm
we're off the chain
so keep listening keep telling your
friends about the show um you know
like-minded people it's not gonna be
forever this will not be for everyone
ya know but it's enough maniacs out
there I hope
Devon Casta what do you think what would
you talk the fight you know calm slash
Devon Casta diva
you're very small you look like a child
I look like an ogre yeah something sent
me a screenshot of that YouTube kinda I
look like I ride you around town yeah
but yeah then I have a podcast on iTunes
hate that you love it with Devin cause I
just type in my name and give it a like
or well where's your social media add
Twitter Sam Devin cause the Devia very
good Twitter's dying though so is it I
don't know I mean I say so I say it was
like it's happen what do I know
yeah there's some crazy [ __ ] in this
podcast but compared to all the other
ones really right well compared to the
actual horrible acts that are also
compared to the rape it's actually fine
yes the jokes are fine go check out the
thing if you haven't already me and Nick
Malin did a fun little half-hour podcast
about Epstein check that out yeah that
was hilarious that was a lot of fun Nick
knows all about this [ __ ] very
interesting we're gonna have him out on
more when he's in LA got a lot of big
guests coming up to very fun stuff good
night everybody